Okay, so this is going to be attendee, it does start with a vowel sound.
>> Nice.
>> Okay, on data type.
>> So this is what it's going to by default make the name, and so I guess
in the case of attendees we'll have real names, we can just leave it as text.
>> And.
>> There's optional features, we can go back
and add them if we need them later.
>> Okay.
>> It's deployed, and actually, you might want to click
to launch the New Custom Tab wizard.
>> Okay. What would have happened if, what does that do?
>> If, it's going to allow us to create a tab automatically, so
we can add it into our app, just like how we have
the festival tab. If we didn't check that box, we could just
go create a tab by going through the setup tree on the left.
>> The tab, so these guys up here?
>> At the top.
>> Home chatter files.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay, so, Save. Oh, New Custom
Object tab. Alright. Object attendee. Tab style.
This is fun. This is just like some image that represents our attendees?
>> Yup. This'll be the image that goes at the top when we click
into the tab. It can be random, it really doesn't matter what it is.
>> No, I want a good one. Okay, people, people, right?
>> That's right.
>> Okay. this optional. If it's optional
I'm basically just going to forget about it, Sam.
>> It's okay, yeah, don't fill it out.
>> Okay.
>> This again is security. Just leave a default on.
That's fine. Everyone will be able to see this tab.
And then this one is actually important, because it's choosing
which apps to add this tab to. So, we don't
really need to include it in all the other ones.
>> Oh.
>> But we want to select the festival app to add it to our festival app.
>> Save.